I learned things from your show I did in
fact um you going to talk about after
dark now we learned something something
no uh if you look over there you see
Kyle you see Kyle sitting right there
yeah does he look familiar to you yeah
I'll show you why roll the
tape now it would be good are there any
more Tik toks oh yeah I'll take if not
I'll take a video question this is after
dark oh yeah let's go over to those okay
okay watch
if you're a butt doctor please stop
scrolling if I have a cut on my arm and
I place feces inside it it will get
infected but if I have a cut or a
hemorrhoid on my butthole when feces
slides past it it does not infect it why
does the butthole wound not get infected
but an arm wound would get infected if
feces were placed inside of it that's a
good question it was a great question I
loved it that's why we hired him and
after we saw that I hired him there he
is right there yeah yeah now now there's
a little code embedded in his question I
I don't remember I do so many shows on
him about there he said butthole
butthole he he he turned the two te's
into sort of a barely a te say
butthole no we can't hear you we can't
hear you butthole oh see he said
butthole that time did you leave the
teas out of the your butt not
intentionally okay because we've made
note that and we've had many butthole
questions over the years on after dark
and women tend to say the word butthole
without the tea they say but hole why
but hole I don't know why it just is the
thing and he said it that way it's one
of the few men I've heard say that way
we have Andrea is in that room Andrea
could you come to the mic Andrea well
now was conscious and aware of it well
maybe we'll see no we'll see Andrea
could you say
butthole but hole oh the tea I didn't
hear the tea the tea was a little light
but she she lean on come closer to the
mic well now she's Focus I'm thinking
about don't think about it try not to
think about it what happens when you
when you rub feces on a but hole say
that when I personally rub feces on my
butthole okay she said she that was
enough of a tea I would so anyway okay
well we don't know how good G though
she's been listening to this and she
true I feel like that doesn't she's an
orator clearly she's perfect diction and
she's arod and so she's a bir butthole
arod arod you say butthole perfectly you
say butthole wow so she didn't spill her
teeth very talented right and so should
we answer the question oh do you want to
I don't know is that I think if I if I
remember how I answered I would still
stand by it is that that there's a
highly specialized tissue down that area
and Bo the immune system the lymphatics
the thickness of the suus layer is just
all very very different down there and
it's not the same as say a wound on your
armus the squamous do you have any other
questions Kyle
yeah oh um who follow on I I was
wondering so like you
know feces this is going to be your
highest rated shows yes you know getting
into this material okay really I didn't
know I didn't know from politics to to
more
politics sometimes feces grows things
like mushrooms and if you eat them you
know you can feel good and you you see
colors and you have a good time but
that's not but the mushrooms and the
feces the Fe is just the environment for
growth it doesn't affect the
hallucinogenic properties of the of the
mushroom okay yeah because if you eat
the feces then you get sick so I was
wondering why you get sick from the
feces but not from those mushrooms did
did you the Fe the mushrooms don't take
up the feces and the bacteria in the
feces that make you sick but most
feces I mean they don't did you throw up
after taking a a FEC Infected Mushroom
once no not not from the mushroom did
you know somebody to take a or you just
think if you were to eat the feces you'd
get sick you worried about that you know
that no Fe okay feces you know you
you're going to be disgusted and have a
you might have a reaction to it in the
What's called the chemo receptor
triggers onto the brain where it just
causes an emission but it's not because
it makes you ill okay for the fees to
make you ill it has to have something
infectious in it like eoli or salmonella
or ch or something or viruses so what
you're saying is you can eat clean [__]
you can eat [__] you you well it's oh
man you were getting into this after
dark territory you you want to go all
the way mhm you can't eat [__] well
because people engage in sexual
practices butthole play where why did
you point to me because you said the
word why did you point to my daughter
she said the word when you say butthole
play point at me not my daughter and
people put their put their mouths there
and they don't get ill but there are if
you but but worldwide oral feal
transmission of infectious diseases is
the leading cause of infectious disease
and death worldwide it's just we don't
have a lot of that stuff here so it
didn't come from it came from when they
Co did it come from our ass so if you're
going to eat poop or someone's butthole
you do it here in the US did you have
hear how she said it you didn't use the
tea I didn't no did you hear it play it
back can you play it back play it back
we will and we will and po I swear God
there's something here all right or not
there was no team but I was going to say
you should do it in the US is what
you're saying don't go Western Europe
yeah